paternity test should be mandatory
like at birth with kids
paternity well to find out who the
father yes oh yeah absolutely yeah
who's the daddy
yeah because imagine i need to know yeah
yeah yeah because imagine how many
like
imagine how many families there are when
like that's not actually their dad or
something like yeah
it's probably more common than people
think it's good for clarity it's good
for next steps in life because imagine
you don't know you have a kid out there
or the kid you're looking after is not
yours that's my like that's what jeremy
cow show is there for
you
so you have you would have um doctor sue
or wherever the hell is
the father fulfill whatever
i feel like women would get offended if
you're like not like i want a dna test
or something like they're going to be
like what do you think i've cheated or
like well yeah
i feel like women would be like they'll
take that as like
what you think i'm cheating or like
yeah like not trusting yeah but i
definitely feel like it's good for
clarity do you think a woman should be
able to go to jail if she
has a guy raising someone else's kid so
let's say he spent five years raising a
kid that wasn't his was she aware of it
yes she knew oh
she knew and put him in that situation
because he spent five years of his life
raising the kids so shouldn't she spend
five years of her life in jail i think
joey
who's gonna look after the kid then
i gotta
maybe like a
three-month sentence or something
five years that's extremely i just well
i think having a guy raise someone
else's kid for five years is extreme but
i wouldn't say like jail time maybe just
have to repay him yeah like a [ __ ] yeah
but he can't get back his time
energy investments emotional investment
looking after a kid for five years and
then go in jail for five years like i
feel like going to jail for five years
it's a lot worse okay let's let's do one
year
i don't think like joe was gonna like
what's that gonna solve her with a huge
fine yeah
what if she can't pay it yeah well she
wants monthly installments is a thing
okay okay so what happens when you can't
pay where do they take you
you're somehow taking care of this child
so you're probably working
i just i just think moving forward
they should go to jail for it because i
think that women should know that like
you can't do that
like there's a difference between
there's a difference between being
afraid of a fine and being afraid of
literal jail time like do you don't you
think that would make women think twice
before doing it
i think yeah but just not that long
yeah i don't feel like joe's the right
the right punishment i feel like they
need to go on like a
i don't know like a course or something
or of course
dr phil
is there a course that says don't sleep
with other people when you're in a
relationship and pin it on them
like like ultimately taking away the mom
from the kid at the age of five or
whatever and putting her in jail for
five years that's hurting the kid as
well i think like she said like just
paying installments like
fine or something but that still hurts
the kid because what if like
no but that's not as bad as going to
jail
right i guess i guess i get where you're
coming from because if that was the case
then nobody would ever do that because
of the repercussions of being with your
children so it would be an effective
punishment because
if as a mom if you know you're not going
to be with your child if you do
something something and you're not going
to you just never no woman would ever do
that well it just i think my point more
is whenever like i i bring up a more
extreme punishment for women like it
just seems like as a society and usually
when i have guests they're like oh no
don't do that
like but it doesn't seem like it's the
same for men
i just think when kids are involved in
something else
and like yeah but sometimes but men go
to jail for not paying child support
that happens
so why why don't women go to jail for
pinning a little or like wasting years
of a man's life
that's a good point
but the the
the man he's going to love that child
either way because
so that makes it worse although although
you're not like dna or whatever like you
you're
you're you're going to be with that
woman because she said that's your child
so you look so you love her and you love
that's your family like you can't i
don't know i feel like you're going to
have an emotional bond to that just
because someone says no and that's not
your yeah but if you if you break up
you're not obligated to i mean you will
be but after four years you're still
going to be the child it depends it's
it's like it's like having a friend that
you've grew up with it's like
that's like your brother like you feel
like
you like that's your boy like but you're
not actually
um
you're not blood related just not dna
but yeah sometimes
your
friends or people that are not actually
related to you are closer than your
actual family yourself yeah
yeah
yeah i mean so because you have a bond
with it the women shouldn't have
consequences or extreme consequences
because you bonded with the kids yeah i
still feel like it should have
consequences but like
i feel like most men if they was looking
after a child for five years they're not
going to be like nah that's not my child
now
they're obviously at first i'm gonna
like what the hell maybe like not see
them for a couple months but i feel like
they're still gonna love like that
they've loved that child so it's gonna
be like what i'm saying is what if if
that's not your child then she cheated
on you so
most men are not gonna stay so if you're
not staying are you still raising the
child whilst not being in a relationship
like so you get complicated you wasted
five years taking care of this kid what
you're gonna spend another like 13 that
doesn't really make sense yeah that's
true and you're gonna put all that your
time energy resources into what
so you've wasted all this time and it's
the same thing like men don't get oh
that's too extreme when they have to go
to jail for child support you don't see
people marching the streets for that
but a woman can literally pin a guy
yeah
for years
and i i don't think there's any
punishment as far as i know
it's wrong
it is wrong it just seems like there's a
lack of like accountability for women in
society i don't i don't think there's a
good enough reason that's why the woman
would lie about that
lying about a kid being okay she may
have cheated yeah like the woman said
that's your son when it's not your son
like
why would like there's loads of cheese
she probably doesn't want the
relationship to break up yeah what if
he's paying the bill like if if a girl
is paying the bills and not really
attracted to a guy because that happens
like girls will marry a dude because he
can take care of her not because she's
actually attracted to her so then she
cheats with the guy she's actually
attracted to like physically yeah gets
the kid from him but takes the resources
from the other guy
the man wastes years of his life
finds out it's not his and there's no
punishment oh oh no that should be a
punishment
that's crazy so like would you
would you then change your mind and say
maybe she should go to jail or do you
stand back it has to be a harsh
consequence because that's crazy doing
all that yeah
what do you think you guys change your
mind still jail no jail
lock her up lock her up
jail go around and if she's like what's
it called like not being um
remorseful or like
being forgiven like saying like no like
i don't know he deserved it or whatever
like i feel like yeah she needs to go to
jail i think it doesn't matter if she's
remorseful if i steal from you it
doesn't matter if i say sorry i should
go to jail if you pin a kid on someone i
don't think it matters if you're
remorseful go you lock her up i think
the hard part for me is the kid because
i wouldn't want to put a kid in a system
that fails kids all the time sending her
from home to home to home so do you
think they should when other people
commit crimes so